I'm in a prison we're all in prison this
is the great equalizer okay this is
flattened everybody we flattened
everyone we're the same now we all bleed
red blood I'm not going anywhere and
it's not easy it's hard it's very very
tough about having to be over you don't
have to clean everything myself I'm
enjoying making my own food worrying
about money and food and all these
ridiculous things baptize yourself
we lost throw the towel nature fought
back and won so just she'll get cozy
have a slumber party for six months I
don't know how to even work this I
thought this was hand sanitizer it's a
slumber party for the rest of your life
we have to make changes in our lives I
miss having a dominatrix come over here
and choke me till I come we're all in